Can you do this one?
I think so.
All right.
I'm going to put my finger
over this hole...
Mm-hmm.
...light it, suck in...
Yeah.
...and then when I'm ready,
I move my finger.
Get that off of there.
Okay, I think I'm ready.
I think I'm ready.
Get it all. Yeah.
One time,
when I first smoked weed,
I didn't suck in,
and then I was just
slowly burning my flesh.
I still, to this day,
have issues
with these things.
Oh, boy.
What?
No, that was just --
you got a big hit there.
Oh, there you go.
[ Laughs ]
I got scared
when you called it big.
[ Laughs ]
[ Whistles ]
What do you think
about this case?
Man, I think Warren's
a shady dude.
He's got shady eyebrows.
He's got the eyebrows
of a villain.
You're right.
He's got the, uh,
sort of the jaw line
and the overall size
of, like,
a Gaston from --
I bet you -- you know...
"Beauty and the Beast."
...he doesn't like a girl
who reads.
No.
[ Laughter ]
He's got, like,
just one line of teeth.
I don't want to --
[ Chuckles ]
I don't want to...
[ Laughs ]
...judge him entirely
on his appearance...
Okay, that's true.
...'cause he's also weird.
Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
But I think that wasn't
the wisest purchase
for their family...
Right.
...because, for example,
I have bought a car before.
I would have never have paid
$47,000 for it.
She kind of rolled her eyes
when I said $47,000 car,
like, "Yeah,
it's kind of crazy,"
but it's like, also,
"Yeah, but you're
still doing it."
Yeah.
"You're still trying to buy
a $47,000 car."
And you're talking to
a shady, you know, character
played by Puddy
from "Seinfeld."
Exactly.
$47,000 was not
a fair price.
What is happening?
I thought so, too.
She had a --
Like, the evidence --
Did she give a deposit
and not get the truck?
That's all
we need to know.
That's the truth.
I was like,
"do you have that $2,000?"
He was like, "This and that.
Of course. Duh."
But that was --
He was also flirting, though.
With me?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hmm.
Listen, I don't think
he's a bad guy,
but how do you feel about
being tied to train tracks?
[ Laughs ]